I want to bring you a Fox News Alert  tonight this one reported just minutes  ago on South Korean media not your  reported in this country in South Korea  they're reporting that North Korea  apparently has fired a short-range  ballistic missile that if true would be  the first time North Korea has done that  in the past year and a half the launch  apparently came from the hodo peninsula  and the missile moved in the direction  of the EC the US officials are analyzing  details to find out exactly what  happened but it would be a significant  setback of course the administration's  diplomatic efforts in the region which  sought to reduce tension between the two  countries will keep following the story  and bring you more information as it  comes in as it doubtless will